[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
>> Mr. President, as Faculty
Marshal I have the distinct
honor to declare this the
119th commencement ceremony
of Carnegie Mellon University
is authorized by the board
of trustee to be in session.
[ Applause ]
[ Music ]
Please rise for the singing
of the national anthem
by the vocal performance
class of 2016.
[ Singing ]
[ Applause ]
>> Good morning!
We are gathered this
morning in a wonderfully free
and collaborative place of
study of work and living.
We are diverse in our
field of study, our talents
and abilities, our ethnicities
and the places that
we call home.
In light of a respect for others
and with the acknowledgment
of differences, I invite you
to join me if you are able
as we pray for this day
and the class of 2016.
All mighty God, we gather today
to celebrate the diligent work.
of the Carnegie Mellon
University Class of 2016.
We pause for a moment
to give thanks to those
who have helped these
students achieve this day.
For the parents, the family,
the friends and peers, teachers
and coaches and all others
who have provided support
for these students.
We choose this day to be
grateful for the vision
and direction of those who have
helped make Carnegie Mellon
University into the
school that it is today.
We give thanks to the board of
trustees, professors, teachers,
and staff, administration of the
university to continue to carry
on the vision of having a
transformative impact on society
through continual innovation
and education research,
creativity and entrepreneurship.
Continue to teach these
students and us as well to look
with compassion on
others both near and far.
Take away any arrogance or
hatred that may influence us.
And give us grace and the
ability to love our neighbors
and to seek peace in
all areas of life.
Bless these students as
they enter the next stages
of their lives and seek to
reach their full potential.
Be with them as they take steps
in the known and to the unknown.
May all that they
do and the decisions
that they make honor
you and the tradition
of Carnegie Mellon University.
We send them forth to impact
society in transformative ways
through their work, their
lives, and their partnerships.
Bless also the rest of the
world that we may learn to love.
Be with us this day and
let these students bring
great glory.
Our heart is in the work.
Amen.
[ Applause ]
>> All right good morning.
Ladies and gentlemen,
OK you might
as well sit down and relax.
In behalf of the Board of
Trustees let me welcome you
to the 119th commencement of
the Carnegie Mellon University.
My name is Jim Rohr it's my
honored and pleasure to serve
as the Carnegie Mellon
Board of Chairman Trustee--
Chairman of the Carnegie
Mellon Board of Trustees
and address you briefly to today
in my first experience
as the chair.
To all the students
graduating today, let me begin
by congratulating you
and your achievement.
This degree obviously
represents years of hard work
and self discipline,
of discovery
and different problem solving.
There's no question that today
the Carnegie Mellon University
degree is more important
and more representative
and more inspiring than it
ever has been in the past.
The combination of the arts
and science is coming
together the way they are
around the world is
recognize here on this campus.
And also it's recognized
that you have surpassed
the highest standard
of accomplishment in
science, art and ideas
and that you're ready to
use all of that knowledge
for the rest of your lives.
Congratulations to you
all, if we can have a round
of applause for the graduates.
[ Applause ]
Just o n a quick
personal note in addition
to my own congratulations, a
few items about Carnegie Mellon,
one is its known for hard
work and if you think
about success there is no
success without hard work.
I'm going to give you a
prediction today I have a 95%
confidence level that each
of you will be successful
and I really do believe that.
But to the extent as to how
success you are, one there has
to be some good fortune but
there is to be hard work,
there's no question about that.
There's has to be collaboration
because in teamwork,
teams over the long run
defeat the individuals they're
more successful.
So teamwork is critically
important in the collaboration
that you've learned
here on the campus
at Carnegie Mellon will serve
you extraordinarily well,
extraordinarily well
into the future.
Thirdly values, there's
no question
that if you live you values
you well be more successful
in the long run.
Stop and ask your
self from time to time
if you're doing the right thing
a simple question like that.
Don't forget integrity, don't
forget to respect others,
you can't be a good teammate
if you have no integrity
and you can't be a good teammate
if you don't respect the others.
My last point would be
humility, it takes humility
to be a good teammate
and remember
that arrogance kills,
arrogance kills.
What you think about
humility, none of you got
to this graduation
point by yourselves all
of you have friends, family
members, mentors, faculty,
staff who take great pride in
what you've accomplish today.
And it takes quite a team effort
to be able to achieve a diploma
from an institutional
of this quality.
You couldn't have done it
without them, so right now I'd
like you to join me in thanking
those people who have led you
and helped you to achieve
this wonderful accomplishment.
[ Applause ]
Now, with us today at our 119th
commencement are some faculty
and students from Carnegie
Mellon other locations
around the world.
We're delighted to have
them here today as graduates
of Carnegie Mellon
they are ambassadors
of a distinctive university.
It was here that all of
them gained solid grounding
in their field of major
studies as all of you have.
It was here that you
learned how to collaborate
with people whose
backgrounds were very different
from your own.
And it was here that
you discover new ideas
about the world and
aspects of your self.
So with those of you around the
world that are joining us today,
thank you for being here and
for those who are graduating,
congratulations to you.
Now, another group that's
here is the board of trustees.
It's their job to uphold
the value of the university,
to work with the administration,
to develop the aspirations
for the university
and to make sure
that there's a strategic
plan that it's being executed
in order to fulfill
those aspirations.
We have a number of
those trustees here
in the platform this morning.
I would like them, please
if they could stand
and be recognized.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
Well this year, Carnegie
Mellon has added
to its remarkable momentum to
the number of new initiatives
and partnerships that are
contributing to its growth
of knowledge, a growth of
knowledge in the world.
We're moving forward
rapidly with distinctive
and collaborative education,
ambitious research programs
in areas ranging from
energy, data science,
workings of the brain and
even the science of learning.
A campus footprint is growing
with plans fully under way
for spectacular new
spaces design
to make CMU a standard center
for the 21st century higher
education with emphasis
on collaboration across
fields of expertise,
creative problem
solving and innovation.
Behind all of these growth
and expansion is our
dynamic president
who joined the university
in 2013
from the National
Science Foundation
and who is already had
a tremendous effect
on the institution.
It's my great privilege now to
introduce the ninth president
of Carnegie Mellon
University Dr. Subra Suresh.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you Jim,
good morning everyone.
Congratulations to
all the graduates.
Commencement is always a
very special day not just
for the graduates, not just
for the Carnegie Mellon
University community but also
for family, friends,
faculty and staff.
But more than anything else
it's a milestone for you
to celebrate your
accomplishments.
You worked very hard to get
here and you are all here--
we all here to salute you.
As you may know it's a
Carnegie Mellon tradition
to entrust the conditions of
the weather for the commencement
with the provost
of the university.
And this academic year
we further expanded
that responsibility for the
provost by unofficial resolution
by the faculty senate that if
the provost doesn't deliver
on the weather, we have the
right to dunk the provost.
Of course, a small incentive
goes a long way as you can see.
Let me start by expressing
my sincere appreciation
to our Chair of the Board
of Trustees, Jim Rohr,
for being an excellent
partner as Chairman
of the Carnegie Mellon
University Board of Trustees.
In a short time, just
starting July 1 of last year,
Jim has brought the vision,
leadership and energy
to Carnegie Mellon
that made him one
of nation's greatest businessman
and a household name in the city
of Pittsburgh and the region.
This has helped the university
make immediate improvements
while also laying a great
foundation for the future.
On a personal note, it's been
my enormous honor and privilege
to have the opportunity to serve
this great institution along
with Jim Rohr.
I would also like to recognize
three long serving dedicated
leaders of Carnegie
Mellon, Michael Murphy,
Cheryl Hays and Fred Gilman.
Michael, who came to Carnegie
Mellon in 1982 is stepping
down as vice president
for Campus Affairs
but will remain affiliated
with teaching
and education in
the Heinz College.
Over a remarkable
quarter of century or more
in senior leadership, Michael
Murphy has served as dean
of students and for the last
seven years as vice president.
He has brought dedication,
compassion, and deep integrity
to all that he has done and
that legacy will benefit the
university for years to come.
He's also been a great
counselor and a friend to me.
Thank you, Michael.
[ Applause ]
After 16 years of tireless
service to Carnegie Mellon,
Cheryl Hays will step away from
her valued role as secretary
to the board of the trustees
and as senior adviser
to the president and will
retire at the end of June,
the end of next month.
Cheryl has been a huge
asset to Carnegie Mellon,
helping to lead several
governance reviews of the board
and streamlining and enhancing
the work of the board.
She played an important role in
the preparation for and approval
of CMU Qatar Campus more than 12
years ago, as well as the design
and construction of
the Posner Center,
the board's full--
first full-time home.
On a personal note,
Cheryl played a key role
in the presidential search
process that brought me
to Carnegie Mellon University
and in helping me and my wife,
Mary, to transition to
Carnegie Mellon University
and to Pittsburgh from
Washington D.C. and Boston.
Carnegie Mellon will miss
her care for the board
and love for the university.
Thank you, Cheryl.
[ Applause ]
And Fred Gilman, Dean
of the Mellon College
of Science is stepping
down from the position
which he has held since 2007.
Fred has led the MCS faculty
in a comprehensive rethinking
of undergraduate
science education,
building on the college's
strong history
of research and education.
Once a successor is named very,
very soon, Fred will refocus
on his research into
high energy theory
on his education
responsibilities
as the Buhl Professor
of Theoretical Physics.
But always the Mellon
College proponent,
he plans to continue helping the
college secure external support
and, of course, internal
support.
Fred has been a great
champion of the college
and pillar of Carnegie Mellon.
Thank you very much,
Fred Gilman.
[ Applause ]
I would now like to recognize
a number of alumni groups
that are in attendance today.
Not those of you who are about
to become alumni but those
who are already alumni.
The 2016 Alumni Award Honorees,
would you please stand first.
[ Applause ]
The Class of 1966 50th reunion
celebrants, please stand.
[ Applause ]
As you know, Carnegie Tech
became Carnegie Mellon in 1967,
so it's a very special
reunion class.
CMU volunteer leaders, who
welcomed the graduates and serve
as alumni marshals for the
colleges, will you please stand.
We know you are here
working very hard.
[ Applause ]
And of course, our
legacy families,
we want to recognize
you as well.
Carnegie Mellon is a beloved
tradition in so many families
and we are always pleased to
see successive generations
of family members
attending Carnegie Mellon.
All CMU alumni here today
are specially designated
by the blue stalls
they are wearing.
We are happy to see so
many of you back home here.
Would all CMU alumni in
attendance, please stand
and be recognized now.
[ Applause ]
It's wonderful to have you here
and I hope I our new graduates
today continue this tradition
and return to commencement
in the future.
One alumna, who was
certainly keen on returning
to Carnegie Mellon is your
new Alumni Association Board
President, Debbie Yu,
Dietrich College Class of 1989.
Debbie joined the Alumni
Association Board in 2010,
now co-chairs its
nominating committee
and will begin her active
term as president in July.
While she was earning
her bachelor's degree
in technical writing at Carnegie
Mellon, she was a reporter
for the "Tartan" and
was active in her pre--
in the Pre-Law Society.
Now a partner at the firm of
Gallagher Sharp in Cleveland,
Ohio, Debbie has been
an active volunteer
for the Northeast Ohio Alumni
network since 2007 having
so previously as
network president.
She also volunteers
as a Carnegie Mellon admission
interviewer and is active
in a number of professional
and community organizations.
I'm sure she will be
a great representative
for all of CMU alumni.
I very much look forward
to working with Debbie
in the next few years.
Now, I would like to
invite her to the podium.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you President Suresh.
It is my honor to be here
today representing the Alumni
Association in congratulating
you, the future community
and industry leaders,
entrepreneurs,
industry representatives,
engineers, writers,
artists and the list goes on.
More than feeling honored
though, I am excited.
I'm of course excited for you
in reaching this milestone.
I remember all too well the
hard work that it takes to get
to this point and commend you.
I am however, excited
for another reason,
very soon you'll discover the
true strength of your education
that you received here at
Carnegie Mellon and the power
of being a Carnegie
Mellon alumni.
Very soon you'll see
that the perseverance
and intellectual curiosity
that helped make you reached
this point will serve you well
as you enter the next
phase of your career.
As a Carnegie Mellon alumni,
doors will open for you
and also you'll have
opportunities
to grow professionally
and personally.
That however, will come
with work on your part.
To borrow a quote
from Andrew Carnegie,
"Anything worth having
is worth working for."
Therefore, it is important
that in order for you
to harness the true potential
of being a Carnegie Mellon
alum, that you work at it.
So you need to stay
connected with the friends
that you've made here
at Carnegie Mellon
and help each other succeed.
In addition to nurturing
that Carnegie Mellon network
that they've already started,
you'll need to grow that network
by attending alumni
events on campus,
in your hometown and
around the world.
So how do you find
these opportunities?
You'll need to stay connected
with the Alumni Association
by updating your contact
information in connecting
with your regional
alumni chapter.
And as you see, your Carnegie
Mellon Alumni network row,
you'll see that you'll
benefit of being part
of this exclusive
alumni community.
Now, remember, you
also have a lot
to offer the Carnegie
Mellon Alumni network.
So, if your professor or dean
asks you to speak on a panel
or to mentor a student,
say, yes.
If you have a job or internship
opportunity at your company,
help recruit Carnegie Mellon
students and graduates.
If you're asked to interview
a student looking to apply
to Carnegie Mellon or to
get involved in volunteer
for the university and for
your regional network, do it.
Not only will you find it
to be personally rewarding
but you'll also be
playing an important role
in maintaining our vibrant
alumni community, which will,
in the long run, benefit you as
well as those who follow you.
On behalf of the Carnegie Mellon
Alumni Association and Board,
it is my pleasure
to congratulate you
and to welcome you into the
Carnegie Mellon community
of over 100,000 alumni
living around the globe.
We're excited to see what
the future holds for you
and wish you nothing
but the best.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you, Debbie.
A member of the Science and
Humanities Scholars Program,
today, Sophie Rose Zucker,
is earning a bachelors degree
in chemistry with university
honors and a bachelor's degree
in creative writing
with college honors.
Sophie has been an active member
of the Carnegie Mellon Community
serving on the executive board
of Alpha Chi Omega
sorority, president of MORF,
CMU's feminist club and
editor-in-chief of the
"Oakland Review," CMU's
literary magazine.
Following graduation, Sophie
will work for Epic Systems
of Madison, Wisconsin,
a software company
for healthcare organizations.
Sophie.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you for that wonderful
introduction, Dr. Suresh.
Thank you everyone.
How do I look?
[Laughs] All right, let's begin.
My heart is in the work.
Those words have followed us
throughout our college careers,
haven't they?
They were pressed into our
minds during orientation,
spoken with passion and rigor
by university officials,
upper classmen and
staff, as they promised us
that we too would put
our hearts in the work.
We would be Andrew Carnegie.
When I was a high school
junior, those words inspired me.
My favorite subject
in school was Latin
and I thought I would
never drink in college.
Oh, sorry it's raining guys.
I walked through
Carnegie Mellon's campus
and I saw myself here, in a
worlds of people passionate
about their studies and
passionate about the future.
When I was a freshmen, "My heart
is in the work," challenged me.
I think it challenged
all of us, right?
Challenged us to sign up for
the most student organizations
at the activities fair.
I don't know about you
but I think I'm still
on the "Tartans" D-list.
Challenged us to take on classes
we knew we probably shouldn't be
taking as freshmen despite
our adviser's recommendations,
and challenged us to step
out of our comfort zones.
Sometimes, "My heart in the
work," translated to work hard,
play hard, and each of us
interpreted that in our own way.
Maybe it was going to
my first college party
and seeing a guy breath
fire in front of me.
Maybe it was my friend, who
called me at 6:30 in the morning
from a walk home
down Morewood just
to tell someone her secrets.
Or maybe it was my
roommate, who started research
with faculty her freshman
year and saw the path
to her future laid out in
front of her bright and clear.
As we progressed through
college though, "My heart is
in the work" took
on a nasty meaning.
It became a curse, a
pejorative, a joke.
It became something we muttered
at 3 a.m. while struggling
through our problem sets
or during long weekends
in practice rooms
and acting studios.
Were our hearts really
in the work
as we planned another event,
we knew nobody would attend.
And were our hearts in the
work at midnight on Sundays
in Hunt library trying
to finish lab reports,
gorging on snack
food and Red Bull.
In the middle of
my sophomore year,
I sat in my adviser's office
asking him for guidance
about what to do that summer.
I didn't know where to go.
I felt like I should start
doing research because everyone
in the chemistry
department does research
and sophomore summer was
too late to start research
and I wanted to take
more writing classes
and I wouldn't have time for
research during the year,
I just couldn't do at all.
I grew frantic, panicked
and I was about to cry
when he just calmly looked
at me and he said, "Sophie,
over the past year,
it had seemed
that chemistry has
excited you less and less
and other things have
excited you more."
And just like that, a whole
world opened up for me.
The thing was I loved
putting my heart into work.
I think we all did, right?
I loved hearing my friends
tell me about their research
and I love the moment
I understood what they
were saying.
I got the science,
yehey, science,
but it meant something
special to them
and it didn't mean
anything special to me.
I had spent time
and energy and heart
on a field I thought I could
settle into and settle for.
But when it came down to it, I
realized it was stupid to settle
when other people weren't.
I realized the things that have
brought me the most satisfaction
during my time here were
outside the classroom
of my primary major and
I don't think I'm alone.
It's not that my heart
wasn't in the work,
it was just in other work.
It was in other classes, in
another academic department
that wasn't on the path
I imagined for myself
but that made me feel like
I was doing something new,
something meaningful.
But, two majors weren't enough.
Is enough ever enough
for CMU kids?
I threw myself into planning
recruitment with my sorority,
Alpha Chi Omega,
and I spent hours
with the feminist club
watching with glee
as I saw an entire lecture hall
filled with students taking time
to hear about women's bodies.
It was more than
just other work.
I found love in late night
meetings with executive boards,
performing weird skits with
the Chemistry Department
and building a booth.
Extracurriculars became
another academic program,
another degree, another
world outside problem sets,
a world of GroupMe text, Doodle
Polls and Google Calendar.
Who among us doesn't
know these worlds?
Whether we were RAs, TAs,
research team members,
team captains or
chapter presidents,
no one is leaving this campus
without having been a part
of something outside the
work we set out to do.
Why did these activities seem to
matter just as much if not more
than another assignment to turn
in by the midnight deadline?
Somewhere along the line,
the people around us
became friends we connected
with on a different level
than just getting things done.
You've probably heard that
we're among the smartest,
best educated, most
privileged people in the world.
Well, duh.
Despite the trials
and difficulties,
each of us have faced
both inside and outside
of this tiny, tiny campus.
We are all incredibly lucky to
be above all else super smart.
Come on, pat yourself
on the back smart asses.
You know what that
means, don't you?
We can't waste our brains.
We have an obligation to
do things that matter.
Carnegie Mellon has not been
an amazing experience just
because of our classes.
As we head out to careers,
to graduate programs,
to our parent's coaches, we
must realize that sometimes,
what made us happiest at
CMU wasn't the work itself,
it was the heart put into things
and the care, it was the TAs
who guided us through concepts
of mathematics and the friends
who helped us solve problems
that would never end,
the advisers and professors,
who guided us towards paths
with meaning and purpose and
the times we became mentors,
leaders and guides.
"My heart is in the
work", doesn't tell us
to mindlessly dedicate
our hearts
to working for the sake of work.
It's a promise to
bring heart into work,
to do the things
we do with heart,
with passion and with care.
Now, I'm not saying each of
us should dedicate our lives
to solving the world's
biggest problems,
although like at least
one of us should do
with the sustainable
energy crisis.
Chemical engineers, maybe
material science, one of you,
can one of you take of that.
Thank you.
But honestly most
of us are going
to spend the next five
maybe 10 years doing stuff
that isn't our dream job
and that's OK, it's normal.
The things, I found myself,
able to put the most passion
into during my time here
were outside the classroom.
Maybe work will be
like that too.
Maybe some of us will struggle
to find meaning in the nine
to five, in tax forms and hour
long commutes but what I ask
of all and what I
hope for my self is
that we put our hearts
into a work.
We know how to work hard,
we've spent how many
years practicing it?
Our more challenging work will
be to work with our hearts.
To bring not only skill, talent
and intelligence but kindness,
thoughts and love into
what we do everyday,
into our work places,
communities and families.
To treat the people outside
the Carnegie Mellon bubble
with the same respects
and wide-eyed wonder
as we treated each other.
To view the world as
optimistically as we did here.
While Andrew Carnegie is--
was a great business man,
he is not remembered
for his business.
He's remembered for his
philanthropy, Carnegie Hall,
Carnegie Museums, the
Carnegie Libraries,
Carnegie Mellon University.
Andrew Carnegie spends his
entire life putting his hearts
into work but his great sorrow
was to wait until the end
of his career to put heart into
the arts, education, service,
the good of the common man,
the things he cared about.
Why shouldn't we in
spirits of innovation,
improved upon his legacy.
As we leave Class of 2016,
let's make, "My hearts is
in the work," a promise to
bring our hearts into our work.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you Sophie.
Now we come to the presentation
of special doctors degrees
awarded to honor individuals
who have had extraordinary
impact in areas
that reflect Carnegie Mellon's
trends in the arts, sciences,
scholarship and society.
Recipients of these
honorary degrees have
in common a notable
record of achievement
in their chosen fields.
And they've made in their
own domains substantial
contributions to the advancement
of knowledge, the enrichment
of the arts and culture,
are to bettering the
well-being of humanity.
Provost Farnam Jahanian
will present each candidate
and sight the achievements
that merit this honor.
Then all candidates will
together receive their degrees
and their doctoral
hoods, Farnam.
>> Good morning, thank
you President Suresh,
on behalf of the faculty and
to our university community,
thank you for leadership.
[ Applause ]
Before we start, let me also add
my warm welcome to all of you
and extend my congratulations
to the 2016 CMU graduates today.
As President Suresh mentioned,
the provost is responsible
for the weather,
your not laughing.
[laughter]
[ Laughter ]
Well, it's not snowing
so you're welcome.
[ Laughter ]
I was told by the staff
not to off script.
This is only the other time
I'm going to off script.
The 2016 graduates,
are you ready?
[ Cheering ]
Excellent.
Will Holly Hunter,
please come forward.
[ Applause ]
Holly Hunter, since
receiving your Bachelor
of Fine Arts Degree at
Carnegie Mellon in 1980,
your artistic talents
on the stage
and screen have brought
you critical acclaim.
During your climb to stardom,
you have earned devotion
from fans and recognition
from your peers,
including four Oscar, six
Emmy and several Golden Globe
and a Screen Actors'
Guild Nominations.
Your portrayal of Ada in "Piano"
earned you an academy award
for best actress, further
solidifying your position among
the Hollywood elite.
Many of our students might be
familiar with your voice work
as Mrs. Incredible in the
Film "The Incredibles".
Holly, you have had
an incredible career.
Through its all you
have remained loyal
to your Alma Matter, returning
off and to share your wisdom
with the next generation
of actors.
For your outstanding
dramatic achievement
and your contributions
to this university,
Carnegie Mellon is
pleased to award the degree
of Doctor of Fine Arts.
[ Applause ]
Will Robert S. Langer
please come forward.
[ Applause ]
Dr. Langer, with more than
1300 scholarly publications
and nearly 1100 patterns
worldwide,
you are one of the world's
most foremost biotechnologist
and the most cited
engineer in history.
[ Applause ]
As David H. Koch
Institute professor at MIT,
the former chairman of the Food
and Drug Administration
Science Board and a member
of four National Academies,
there has been no shortage
of honors during your career.
Forbes Magazine, named you among
the 25 most important people
in biotechnology.
You have received more than 200
major awards including the US
National Medal of Science
and the National Medal
of Technology and Innovation.
Dr. Langer for your vast
contributions to engineering,
medicine and improving
the human condition,
Carnegie Mellon is proud to
award you the degree of Doctor
of Science and Technology.
[ Applause ]
Will Sonia Manzano,
please come forward.
[ Applause ]
Sonia Manzano, you has
been a treasured member
of our households for
more than 40 years.
Through your iconic role
Maria on Sesame Street--
[ Applause ]
-- you entertained and
educated us during our most
formative years.
And by bringing the
perspective and culture
of your Hispanic heritage
into living rooms everywhere,
you quietly, powerfully and
permanently changed the face
of American television.
Your talent as an actress are
matched only by your skills
as a writer, as evidenced by the
15 Emmy Awards you have shared
with Sesame Streets staff and
the book you have authored--
the books you have authored
including your memoir titled,
"Becoming Maria: Love and
Chaos in the South Bronx".
Earlier this month, you received
daytime televisions' highest
honor, the Emmy Award
for Lifetime Achievement.
[ Applause ]
For your contributions
to television, literature
and for your role in
educating children and adults
around the world,
Carnegie Mellon is honored
to award you the
Doctor of Fine Arts.
[ Applause ]
Will Jim Swartz please
come forward.
Jim Swartz, since earning
your Masters Degree
from the Tepper School
of Business
[ Applause ]
You have become one
of the world's most
successful venture capitalist
with a keen eye for business
and an intrepid entrepreneurial
spirit,
you founded the global
technology investment firm,
Accel Partners.
And your vision drove
investments
in pioneering technology
companies including Facebook,
Spotify, Squarespace and
Dropbox, just to name a few.
In your personal life your
interests are as diversified
as your investment
portfolio, including passion
for film, the arts and sports.
A trustee of the
Sundance Institute
and the San Francisco
Museum of Modern Art,
you are also Director
Emeritus of the US Ski
and Snowboard Foundation.
But your passion for Carnegie
Mellon is truly legendary.
As a result of your
transformational donation
to the university,
the Swartz Center
for Entrepreneurship will
nurture countless generation
of young entrepreneurs.
Jim for your contributions to
global business, technology,
the arts and higher education,
Carnegie Mellon is pleased
to award you the Doctor--
the degree of Doctor
of Business Practice.
[ Applause ]
Will Earl Lewis,
please come forward.
[ Applause ]
Dr. Lewis, you are one of
America's leading champions
of humanities and the arts.
And a tireless advocate
for the power of diversity
and the importance of
technology enhanced learning.
As president of the Andrew W.
Mellon Foundation since 2013,
you have guided the foundation
towards supporting these
principles in higher education.
You are not only a
preeminent scholar,
renowned social historian and
member of the Academy of--
American Academy for
Arts and Sciences.
You're also the author
and coeditor
of seven provocative books on
the African-America experience.
Twenty years ago, then a
professor at the University
of Michigan, Earl, we
were so young back then
and you haven't changed much.
[Laughter] You gave
the inaugurate address
for Carnegie Mellon's Center
for African-American
and Urban Studies.
This past October, we were
honored to welcome you back
to deliver the key note address
for the Center's 20th
anniversary celebration.
For your commitment
and contributions
to higher education
and for your many years
of impactful scholarly
achievements,
Carnegie Mellon is pleased
to award you the degree
of Doctor of Humane Letters.
[ Applause ]
>> Holly Hunter, Robert
S. Langer, Sonia Manzano,
James R. Swartz and Earl Lewis,
by virtue of the authority
granted to me, by the Board
of Trustees, I hereby confer
these honorary degrees upon you
with all the rights,
honors, privileges
and responsibilities
pertaining there to.
Congratulations.
[ Applause ]
Now, I am very pleased to
introduce your key note speaker,
who will deliver remarks
some of you will remember
for the rest of your lives.
Noted social historian
and author and as
of just a minute ago, an
honorary doctored degree holder
from Carnegie Mellon, Earl
Lewis is the sixth president
of the Andrew W.
Mellon Foundation.
In this role, Dr. Lewis has,
reaffirm the foundation's
commitment o the humanities,
the arts and higher education.
Dr. Lewis is also a champion
of diversity in academia,
enhancing graduate education,
re-envisioning liberal arts,
exploring the role of
digital tools in learning
and connecting universities
to their communities.
Previously, he served as provost
and executive vice president
for academic affairs in the
Asa Griggs Candler Professor
of History and African
American Studies
at Emory University in Atlanta.
Among his signature
accomplishments at Emory was
to institutionalize
an effort to sustain
and develop the university's
diversity.
Upon his departure,
he was hailed
as a visionary administrator,
generous mentor
and dynamic educator who
made a lasting impact
as the university's
chief academic officer.
Lewis was elected as a fellow
of the American Academy
of Arts and Sciences in 2008.
And the outstanding achievement
award from the University
of Minnesota and the Harold R.
Johnson Diversity Service Award
from the University of Michigan.
And has earned several
honor and doctorate degrees.
A native of Tidewater,
Virginia--
>> Whoa! That's my city!
[ Laughter ]
>> Hello to all the
one residence
of Tidewater, Virginia.
Lewis earned his undergraduate
degree in History and Psychology
from Concordia College
in Moorhead, Minnesota,
and his PhD in history from
the University of Minnesota.
Just in case, you are wondering,
in a few minute, you all realize
that Dr. Lewis' Minnesota accent
is somewhat very different
from my Iowa accent
a neighboring state.
Dr. Lewis.
[ Applause ]
>> It's actually very nice to
travel the world and realize
that other people have actually
made their way from the Norfolk,
Portsmouth, Tidewater
area to other parts
of the country as well.
So, salute.
Super thank you for
that introduction.
I was reminded that
yesterday would have been my
mother's birthday.
She past away a few years ago,
she would have love
that introduction.
I have to say.
Good morning to you all and I
think it is still good morning.
Good morning!
>> [Simultaneously]
Good morning.
>> Thank you.
We gather this Sunday
morning to salute you.
The Carnegie Mellon
University class of 2016,
for staying the course,
overcoming challenges,
setting aside failures,
appropriately accepting
success and graduating.
This is an awesome achievement
and I'm honored to
share in a moment.
In fact, I would like to thank
Subra Suresh, president of CMU
and Provost Farnam
Jahanian and as well
as the Carnegie Mellon
University Board of Trustees
for this wonderful opportunity
to receive an honorary degree
from this spectacular
institution.
My personal relationship
with Carnegie Mellon began
over three decades ago with
my good friend, Joe Trotter,
Dr. Joe Trotter invited me
to speak about my research
on African-American migrants.
Inevitably that opportunity
yielded the privilege of serving
on the CMU humanities and social
sciences college review panel.
Chairing an external
review committee
for the history department
and having the chance
to assist Dr. Trotter in funding
and launching cause the center
for African-American urban
studies and the economy,
which has just recently
celebrated its 20th anniversary.
Yes, that's great.
[ Applause ]
Now, I am both humble and
delighted to speak on behalf
of this year's very diverse
and distinguished class
of honorary degree recipients.
A group that includes, as
you've heard an acclaimed stage
of screen star who counts among
her accomplishments an Academy
Award, a Golden Globe
and two Emmy's.
A television icon and
Emmy Award winning writer
and actress who's influenced the
lives of millions of children.
A prolific innovator with over
1100 patterns world wide and one
of the most successful venture
capitalist in the world.
Graduates, make a
note to yourself,
learn more about these folks.
It is also an honor to be
standing here before a group
of students that
has been embedded
by the vigorous academic
standards and requirements
of one of the world's
finest universities.
You have been given the Carnegie
Mellon stamp of approval.
And with it comes
at a certain level
of attainment and
responsibility.
Now, many years ago,
as you've heard,
I walked across a similar stage
at a small liberal arts college
in Minnesota to accept
my diploma.
Like many of you, I was
able to join the ranks
of the newly educated because
someone believed in me.
In my case, it was started
with my maternal grandmother.
While her dream was deferred,
she strategized to ensure
that my dream would
not be denied.
It was the early 20th century
and my grandmother
had saved money twice
to attend Saint Augustine
College
in Raleigh, North Carolina.
Each time she did, her father
asked her for the money
to save an older brother
from loosing his home.
The sad truth is he lost
that home during the
great depression.
A domestic in the
segregated south for most
of her working days, my
grandmother preserved her dream
of being educated
by passing it along.
When it came time for my--
her daughter, my mother,
to graduate from high school,
my grandmother send her first
to the Norfolk division
of Virginia State,
today is Norfolk
State University.
But my grandmother feared
the demands of living
at home would distract my
mother from her studies.
So, this God fearing,
church going woman
played the daily number
of what was it referred to back
then as a poor person's lottery.
And she won.
Even though my grandmother
could have used that money
to ease the burdens of her
own life, she chose instead
to send my mother to
Saint Agustin College,
because she believed
just that fervently
in the transformative
power of education.
When I came along, the
only question I was allowed
to entertain was, which
college will you attend?
So, I stand before you today,
because of my grandmother's
determination
to pay a dream forward.
My mother and I inherited
the belief
that the educated
have a responsibility
to pay back the faith
invested in them by working
to in some way, improve
the world.
Let's see, let's
see a show of hands,
how many of you have family,
friends and teachers who back
and supported you through your
higher education experience?
Thank you.
Please join me in recognizing
these special individuals
with a ruckus round of applause.
[ Applause ]
Their job is done.
And in fact, if you listen
closely, you'll hear some sighs
of relief coming from
parents in the audience.
Now, your job like mine
when I graduated is
to never confuse the
attainment of an education
with what it means
to be educated.
Graduation marks
a moment in time
when you have assembled
the necessary credits
to earn a degree.
But, being educated, being
educated requires you
to deploy the discipline of
mind that comes with a pursuit
of knowledge for the
betterment not only of yourself
and your family, but
also, the greater society.
I graduated in a
post-Vietnam era of gas lines,
student protests and
racial desegregation.
I knew what had been and what
was happening at the time.
But, I had no idea
what to expect
in the years and
decades to come.
For example, in 1978,
it was nearly impossible
to conceive of desktop
computers.
Much less, a world so
completely integrated
with powerful personal
computing ability
that resides in the phone.
Just think about that, it
hasn't been that long ago.
Back then, when I
imagined a future,
I pictured a world
akin to Jetson's.
There are people in
this audience old enough
to remember the Jetson's.
A primetime animated series
that predated the
Simpson's by almost 30 years.
It's world was populated
with space age families,
sassy robots and flying cars.
Computers delivered
both instant meals
and instantaneous medical
diagnosis and cures for diseases
where it's just one individually
formulated pill away.
Flash forward to today.
And flying cars are still a
matter of fantasy, but we aren't
that far away from a semi
autonomous automobile.
Gene mapping is almost common
place in the development
of customized treatment plans.
Robotics is now offered
as part of the curriculum
in many high schools
across the United States.
And artificial intelligent
protocols
such as IBM's Watson
regularly beat humans at games
of knowledge and logic.
It is said that at CMU,
you do not imagine the
future, you create it.
But it indulged me
for few seconds.
Look at here, graduates,
look at here to 25 years
from now, what do you see?
Marriage, children, family,
maybe divorce and success.
It's true.
[ Laughter ]
But, what about on
the technology front?
Will it be that the discipline
of robotics is ushered
in a new age of productivity
and profitability.
A world where artificial
intelligence alters the make
up of the work as well as the
composition of the workforce.
Today, a single retailer can
employ nearly 100,000 people
around the nation
to move products
from regional sites
to consumer homes.
That is sort of a speculation,
the robots could replace
these workers in short order,
not next year, but tomorrow.
What happens then?
Do we simply shrug
and acknowledge
that progress always
comes at a price
or do we examine
the broader social
and economic implications.
Graduates, many of you will
certainly be the architects
of the next technological
revolution.
But while you are developing
devices and programs
that enhance deficiency and
perhaps even save lives,
you must also simultaneously
challenge yourselves to solve
for the impact of
these advancements.
As our economy shifts away
from human base work--
from a human base workforce
to machine driven labor,
will you make accommodations
for the newly technologically
disenfranchised?
Undoubtedly, CMU
has prepared you
to meet the exponentially
increasing technological demands
of a growing global economy
in a more environmentally
conscious manner.
But, what additional tools
and insights might you need
to be both successful
contributors
and successful global citizens?
Twenty five years from now
with the courses that you took
in history, philosophy
and literature.
Your experimentation
with theater and the arts
or your inter-disciplinary
courses
and study abroad proved
just as useful as the work
that made you a student
of science,
math and engineering or not.
For those of you in the arts and
the humanities, will the value
of your degree decrease in
a technology focused world
or increase because
people with your background
and training are
suddenly in short supply.
It is critical that all of you
invasion yourselves as part
of a creative society, which
produces creative solutions.
Though historically, we
have looked to those coming
out of the arts and humanities
to help us transform what
we know and how we know it.
Today, engineering, math
and computer science
have truly evolved
into creative disciplines.
More people worldwide
are familiar with theory
that any book, play or essay
written in the last 100 years.
The engineers and technologies
at Apple have created something
that it's infiltrated
our consciousness
like few other works
of art ever have.
And that's actually important
to think about and dwell on
and think through
the implications.
Yet, science, engineering
and math alone are not
enough, case and point, 9/11.
Despite the utilization of
very sophisticated machinery
and highly skilled technicians,
we failed to intercept
the terrorists,
because 9/11 have more to do
with religion and ideology
than with probes, drowns
and surveillance devices.
Similarly, engineers
successfully build a well
in the West African
village not to long ago
to ensure a ready supply of
clean water, yet failed to take
into consideration broader
culture implications.
To their surprise, the women
who haul the water continue
to walk all the way to the
river, despite the risk.
When question by anthropologist,
the women explained
that no one had asked them
where to build the well.
You see, the hauling of the
water had a social function
as well as the utilitarian one.
The women use their time
to socialize and get away
from their children
and the men folk.
Both of these examples serve
as the powerful reminder
that studying a multiplicity
of perspectives has real worth
when we are trying to
solve real problems.
Human interaction, as we
all well know is messy.
It's not always scientifically
based
or mathematically
predictable, nor is it linear.
Sometimes, you simply
cannot get from point A
to point B in a straight line.
This is to suggest that the
world is complex and the issues
that we face are indeed complex.
And that it requires
that technologist consult
with social scientist, that
humanist work with engineers
and that scientist and art has
collaborate to solve problems
and try new possibilities.
Graduates, as we move forward
in life, and as you move forward
in life, you must strive to be
in conversations across lines
of difference, exchange
in insights and ideas
and a profound and noble way
with people of different racial,
academic and socio-economic
backgrounds.
Luckily, today's technologies--
it clips time and distance
making it possible for you
to connect in real
time with people
in different geographic zones
across the United States
and around the world.
You will also need to recognize
the importance of being embedded
in community and
actively working
to improve the American
form of democracy.
That's not just about
voting, it's about the ways
in which we think about
the opportunity for all.
And actually, being able
to gather information
across a broader spectrum
of media that will allow you
to fashion your understanding
of the world.
Or to put it bluntly, to be
able to tell the difference
between garbage and
the real stuff.
Now, if this election cycle is
a harbinger of things to come,
successfully stored
in the garbage
from the real stuff
will become the hallmark
of an enlighten citizen.
Yeah, we can think
about that for a second.
[ Laughter and Applause ]
And this would be true, whether
you are in Berlin, Beijing
or Birmingham, you must
remember to ask why
to research independently
to pursuit truth
and to affirm your
commitment to honesty,
integrity and the common good.
Now, look to the future once
more, to your 25th reunion.
This time, what do you see?
More changes
in the technological
landscape, greater diversity?
How about improve connectedness?
Hopefully, you see your future
selves as inextricably linked
to America and the world,
both the opportunities
and the challenges, because
you haven't shrunk from either.
Keep looking.
Are you a key player
in a creation of a new
and technologically
responsible golden age?
Are you balancing your desire
to create bigger, better,
faster with the need to sustain
a healthy and vibrant economy
in which all members
have a stake?
More specifically,
are you the leader
that Carnegie Mellon has
prepared you to become,
or are you merely participating
in a creation of cool new stuff?
I challenge you, I challenge
you, because you are the best
and the brightest as you've
heard and you will hear,
no doubt, many more times
over the course of this day
and the next few days.
So, graduates of 2016, stand up.
[ Applause ]
And I would ask that
you repeat after me.
We, the 2016 graduating
class of Carnegie Mellon.
>> [Simultaneously] We,
the 2016 graduating class
of Carnegie Mellon.
>> Will do the unimagined.
>> [Simultaneously]
Will do the unimagined.
>> We will discover
the undiscoverable.
>> [Simultaneously] We will
discover the undiscoverable.
>> We will change the world--
>> [Simultaneously] We
will change the world--
>> -- responsibly.
>> [Simultaneously]
-- responsibly.
>> Let's try that one more time.
We will change the
world responsibly.
>> [Simultaneously] We will
change the world responsibly.
>> And then one more time.
We will change the
world responsibly.
>> [Simultaneously] We will
change the world responsibly.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
You may sit down.
If you remain faithful
to this moment in time,
you will have done far
more than earn a degree.
You will have used your
skills, talents and intellect
for the benefit of all.
I am confident that you
understand the significance
and I am grateful to
have had this opportunity
to see you off on your journey.
I'm truly excited for you.
I'm excited for the world
and I extend my sincerest
congratulations.
Do well graduates and
do good because you can.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Dr. Lewis, you have called on
our students to embed themselves
in their communities and
change the world responsibly.
Your own career has
been a reflection
of that same commitment.
It's been an honor to have
you as our key note speaker.
Once again, please join me
in thanking Dr. Earl Lewis.
[ Applause ]
It is now my pleasure to
recognize the faculty members
who have been recently
accept the emeritus status.
Like all of our educators,
these distinguished individuals
are scholars, scientists,
artists and above all, teachers.
I wish to take a moment
to acknowledge the mark
they have made at CMU.
Through the support and
encouragement they have provided
to our students, and through
their tireless commitment
to the pursuit of scholarship.
The names of the 22 retiring
faculty are projected
on the screen.
Those retiring faculty who
are present this morning,
please stand as I
read your name.
Please hold your applause
until I've read all the names.
Diane Covington, Chemistry
and Biology Librarian
at University Libraries.
Al Blumstein, J. Erik
Jonsson University Professor,
Heinz College.
Stephen Fienberg, Maurice
Falk University Professor
of Statistics and Social
Science, Dietrich College
of Humanities and
Social Sciences.
Thomas Ferguson,
Professor of Physics,
Mellon College of Science.
Al Rudnicky Research
Professor of Computer Science,
School of Computer Science.
And, Donald Thomas,
Professor of Electrical
and Computer Engineering,
College of Engineering.
Please join me in thanking all
of the Carnegie Mellon's
Emeritus faculty
for their service and
dedication to the university.
[ Applause ]
I will see you all at that 9th
booth over there at the corner
at the end of the event.
You know, I should have
started the morning
by singing the theme song for
Sesame Street, Sunny Days, but--
I would now like to recognize
those faculty members
who were recently honor with the
title of University Professor.
The title of University
Professor is the highest
designation a faculty member
can receive at Carnegie Mellon.
University professors
are distinguished
by international recognition
and for their contributions
to education, artistic
creativity and/on research.
I am pleased to announce the
three faculty members have
joined the distinguish
ranks this year.
Dominated by the
university of professors,
deans and department
heads and approved
by the President Suresh.
The first newly appointed
University Professor I would
like to congratulate is
Marlene Behrmann, George A.
and Helen Dunham Cowan Professor
of Cognitive Neuroscience,
Dietrich College of
Humanities and Social Sciences.
Marlene, please stand
and be recognize.
[ Applause ]
I'm also pleased to congratulate
the other two University
Professors who could not
be here this morning.
Jonathan Caulkins, Stever
Professor of Operations Research
and Public Policy, Heinz
College and Jelena Kovacevic,
David Edward Schramm Professor
and Head of Electrical
and Computer Engineering,
College of Engineering.
Please join me in
a round of applause
for these new elected
University Professors.
[ Applause ]
We will now begin the formal
conferral of degrees on all
of the students who have duly
completed their requirements
of their programs to the
satisfaction and approval
of their faculty members.
The commencement program gives
each student's degree and area
of study which will be
called out and celebrated
at the departmental
diploma ceremonies.
I encouraged families
and friends to look
and listen beyond just your own
graduates listing to get a sense
of the unique educational
environment at Carnegie Mellon.
And also to appreciate the many
areas of interest and expertise
in this graduating class.
I wish to begin by
acknowledging the achievements
of this year's group
of doctoral candidates.
This outstanding scholars
received their academic hoods
at a special ceremony
yesterday afternoon.
In earning their doctorates,
they have made a commitment
to a life of scholarly pursuits
and have reaffirm the importance
and prominence of
Carnegie Mellon as one
of the nation's premiere
research universities.
I would invite the
doctoral candidates,
please rise and be recognize.
[ Applause ]
There were many,
many more last night.
[ Laughter ]
Please sit down.
In addition, we're pleased today
to officially confer bachelor
degrees to students graduating
from Carnegie Mellon
University Qatar.
These students earned degrees
from the Dietrich College,
the Mellon College of Science
to School of Computer Science
and the Tepper School
of Business.
At this time, I wish
you recognize the Dean
of Carnegie Mellon University
Qatar, Dean Ilker Baybars
who has been an exemplar
leader of our campus in Doha.
Dean Baybars please
stand to be recognized.
[ Applause ]
Candidates, I will now
give you some directions
on what to do next.
Are you ready?
>> [ Simultaneously ]
Yes.
>> We will ask degree candidates
from each college to stand
and be recognized as you are
called upon by your dean.
When all schools and
colleges have been recognized,
President Suresh will then ask
all students to stand again,
at which time, he will
formally confer your degrees.
Are you with me?
>> [ Simultaneously ]
Yes.
>> If you're not, just follow
the person next to you.
For the conferral of degrees
at the university level,
when we call for degree
candidates to stand,
we will be calling for their
broad categories of bachelors,
masters or doctoral
level candidates.
I will now call on the dean
of each school or college
to present its candidate
for degrees.
President Suresh, please
join me at the podium.
To begin, I wish to
recognize James Garrett,
Dean of the College
of Engineering.
[ Applause ]
>> Will the candidates from
the College of Engineering,
please rise with
enthusiasm and noise.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
Mr. President, upon the
recommendation of our faculty,
I have the honor of presenting
the bachelors, masters
and doctoral candidates from
the College of Engineering.
Will the new College
of Engineering graduates
please be seated.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Dan Martin, Dean
of the College
of Fine Arts could
not be here today due
to illness, we wish him--
[ Laughter ]
You don't listen well, either.
>> They're graduating,
they don't have
to listen to you anymore.
[ Laughter ]
>> Dan, if you're watching,
we wish you a speedy recovery.
To present the candidates
from the College of Fine Arts,
on Dan's behalf, I now
recognize Eric Anderson,
Associate Dean, Eric.
[ Applause ]
>> Will all of the candidates
from the College of Fine Arts,
please rise with even
more enthusiasm and noise.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
Mr. President--
[ Cheering ]
Upon the recommendation of
our faculty, I have the honor
of presenting the
bachelors, masters,
and doctoral degree candidates
from the College of Fine Arts.
[ Applause ]
Will the College of Fine Arts
graduates, the new College
of Fine Arts graduates
please be seated.
>> Yes.
>> I now recognize the Dean
of the Dietrich College
of Humanities and Social
Sciences Richard Scheines.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> OK, Dietrich,
the bar is high.
If you can still feel your
toes with the candidates
from the College of
Dietrich, please rise.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
Mr. President, upon the
recommendation of our faculty,
I have the honor of presenting
the bachelors, masters,
and doctoral degree candidates
from the Dietrich College
of Humanities and
Social Sciences.
Please sit.
[ Applause ]
>> I now recognize the Dean
of the Heinz College,
Ramayya Krishnan.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
You may applaud now.
>> Will all the candidates
from the Heinz College,
please rise with the great poise
and the great poise and decorum
that characterizes us.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
Mr. President, upon the
recommendation of our faculty,
I have the honor of
presenting the masters
and doctoral candidates
from the Heinz Colleges.
Will the new Heinz College
graduates, please be seated.
[ Applause ]
>> I now recognize the Dean of
the Mellon College of Science,
Fred Gilman who is
completing his final year
as you heard as Dean.
Fred, your dedication to Mellon
throughout more than eight years
of leadership has
built the foundation
for the College's future
growth and success.
Fred, thank you again
for your service.
[ Applause ]
>> Not to be out done,
will all the candidates
in the Mellon College
of Science, please rise.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
Mr. President, on
the recommendation
of our distinguished
faculty, I have the honor
of presenting the
bachelors, masters
and doctoral degree candidates
from the Mellon College
of Science.
[ Applause ]
Will all the new degree
recipients, please be seated.
>> I now call on the
Dean of the School
of Computer Science,
Andrew Moore.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Will all of those candidates
who are not currently too busy
finalizing your series a round
of funding for your start
ups, from the School
of Computer Science please rise.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
Mr. President, upon the
recommendation of our faculty,
I have the honor of presenting
the bachelors, masters
and doctoral degree candidates
from the Scholl of
Computer Science.
[ Applause ]
>> Please be seated.
I now call on the Dean
of the Tepper School
of Business, Robert Dammon.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> A very nice try for the
other colleges and schools.
But we'll show them
how it's done.
Will the candidates
from the Tepper School
of Business, please rise.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
That's how it's done.
Mr. President, upon the
recommendation of our faculty,
I have the honor of presenting
the bachelors, masters
and doctoral degree candidates
from the Tepper School
of Business.
Will the new Tepper School
graduates please be seated,
thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Carnegie Mellon is
proud to lead the world
in interdisciplinary,
research and education
and nurture several university
wide inter college ad joint
degree programs.
I will now present
the candidates
from these special programs.
Will all the candidates,
bachelors, masters
and doctoral candidates
in our interdisciplinary
programs please rise.
[ Applause and Cheering ]
Mr. President, upon the
recommendation of our faculty,
I have the honor of
presenting the candidates
from our university
wide inter college
and joint degree programs.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
I would ask these candidates
to please remain standing.
I would like to invite
students from all other schools
and colleges to once
again please stand
for the official conferral of
degrees by President Suresh.
President Suresh.
>> Thank you Provost Jahanian.
By virtue of the authority
granted to me by the Board
of Trustees, I hereby conferred
these degrees upon these
candidates with all the
rights, honors, privileges
and responsibilities
pertaining there to.
I'm pleased to join
the deans and faculty
of the entire university
in congratulating you.
Congratulations.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
Will all the new bachelors,
masters and doctoral graduates
of Carnegie Mellon
University, please be seated.
It was just last year that we
reached 100,000 living alumni
of the university in
more than 100 countries,
with this commencement ceremony,
with you graduating today,
we begin CMU march toward
200,000 living alumni.
When I called Earl Lewis
to be our commencement speaker
this year, several months ago,
he asked me what
should he talk about.
I said he can talk
about whatever he
choses to talk about.
We never compared notes, I
had no idea until he started
to speak what he was
going to talk about
and he had no idea what
I'm going to say now.
It's all good.
It turns out that we are
approaching the same,
same theme from very
different angle.
Unannounced to each other, we
are focusing on a similar theme.
Early this year, a group of CMU
faculty members and I traveled
to Switzerland to attend the
World Economic Forum in Davos.
For this meeting, which attracts
world leaders, technologists,
industry leaders, policy
makers, writers, film makers,
performers and the global media.
The World Economic
Forum choose the theme,
"The Fourth Industrial
Revolution."
The first industrial
revolution which started
in the late 18th century,
created mechanization,
specifically according
to one perspective
from the World Economic
Forum, it was the year 1784
and the catalyst for this
revolution was steam,
water and mechanical
production equipment.
A major outcome of this
revolution was the emergence
of industrialize cities
where some form of human
or animal labor could be
replaced by mechanical labor.
Each revolution created more
advance forms of manufacturing
and altered the global
economy in unprecedented
and irreversible ways.
The second industrial
revolution which started
in the late 19th Century
created mass production.
The catalyst for this revolution
considered to have begun in 1870
where the division of labor,
electricity and mass production.
A major outcome of this
revolution was the emergence
of industrialize regions
and economies of scale.
The third industrial
revolution which started
in the late 20th Century created
unprecedented automation.
The catalyst for this revolution
considered to have begun in 1969
where micro electronics
information
and communication
technologies, the internet,
robotics and automation.
A major outcome of this
revolution was the emergence
of global production networks
and the input cost were
significantly altered.
The fourth industrial
revolution which many leaders
who were gathered at the world
economic forum focused on,
is believe to be occurring
now in the early part
of the 21st century,
although no one is quite sure
when exactly it began.
In my view what makes the fourth
industrial revolution unlike the
previous three stems from
at least a few key factors.
The speed of change, the role
of the individual citizen
of the world whether he or
she is educated or uneducated,
is rich or poor lives
in a developed country
or a developing country.
He or she can engage in
a two way communication
at the cutting age of the
fourth industrial revolution
at lightning speed.
Individual empowerment, scale
in which the individual
can do enormous good
and equally enormous harm.
The scope of change, the
impact of that scope of change
on a global system intended
versus unintended consequences,
known unknowns and
unknown unknowns.
You are graduating at a
particularly exciting time
where the convergence
of technologies
and human interactions
with those technologies is
creating new possibilities
and new challenges, new
solutions to problems
and new tracks that
create major new problems
in many domains of
day to day life.
On one hand the convergence
of the digital physical
and biological worlds is
generating unprecedented
questions and concerns
about how governments
and individuals were address
such issues as employment,
income levels, equality,
ethics, security, policy,
confidentiality, social
justice, taxation, diplomacy,
and global attractions.
At the same time the
intersections of the real
and virtual world on the
tag of war between natural
and artificial intelligence of
creating interesting questions
about the ways in which the
21st Century will unfold during
your lifetime.
In your careers, say 50 years
from now, Earl Lewis talked
about the next 25 years, whether
we emerge as better human beings
or not will critically depend
on how you shape the fourth
industrial revolution.
How you use or abuse the
tools at your disposal,
intentionally or intentionally.
Nobody is better prepared
to shape the world
than today's graduates of
Carnegie Mellon University.
CMU faculty, students and
staff played a pivotal role
in their pioneering work that
enabled many of the technologies
that are critical to the
fourth industrial revolution.
Computers and computing,
robotics, mobile communications,
big data, deep learning,
science of learning,
artificial intelligence,
human machine interactions,
tools for cyber security
and the internet of things.
CMU has purposely emphasized
to you during the course
of your education here.
The importance of connecting the
sciences engineering, business
and technologies with human
creativity and the arts,
humanities, social behavior and
decision sciences and policy.
CMU's own Dr. Herbert Simon,
Nobel Prize Winning pioneering
professor, said in 1971,
"A wealth of information
creates a poverty of attention."
To paraphrase it differently,
a wealth of information can
create sometimes enormous
confusion between what
Earl Lewis called,
"Garbage and the real stuff."
Nobody is better prepared
than you to use a wealth
of information deliberately
using careful thought reflection
and evidence to address
major societal problems.
Our five honor degree
candidates are role models
in their important
connection between technologies
and the human condition
that will unfold
in the coming years and decades.
Holly Hunter and Sonia Manzano
used their beginnings at CMU
to excel in the arts
and entertainment world.
And Sonia skillfully combined
the entertainment and education
to inspire a young minds.
Paul Belanger is a
pioneering engineer whose work
at the intersections
of Engineering, Science
and Medicine shaped
new technologies.
Our own alumnus Jim
Schwartz excels
in creating new business
opportunities economic value
and societal impact on a
global scale for those kinds
of rapidly emerging
technologies.
Earl Lewis with a
keen eye and knowledge
of history use the past to
shape the present and future
by applying his intellect
and energy
to expand diversity in academia.
To connect the digital
world with the humanities
and through his leadership roles
in academia and non-profits
as many have said and as I
have said before that some
of the greatest technological
achievements
of the 20th century have played
a major role in creating some
of the toughest grand
challenges of the 21st century.
As CMU graduates and global
citizens you have exceptional
talent and unique cross
disciplinary perspectives
that will enable you to face
and address these tough problems
without creating new challenges
for the next revolution.
My congratulations to you,
to your families and friends
and my enormous gratitude
to you for sharing your time
with us during the
past few years.
Congratulations.
[ Applause ]
You don't have to spend a
lot of time thinking whether
to dunk or not to dunk.
We will conclude
today's ceremony
by singing the Alma Matter
by the Vocal Performance
Class of 2016.
We invite you to please
rise and sing along.
The words to our Alma Matter
can be found in your program.
Also please remain
standing at the end of--
at the conclusion of the Alma
Matter for the recession.
Thank you.
[ Music ]
[ Singing ]
[ Applause ]
[ Music ]